as of guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to episode 14 of the Sparky game engine
series so last time we covered groups
and today we're going to finally begin
our great an epic journey into texturing
and textures by by basically
implementing image loading so in order
to avoid the whole let's write a parser
and decoder and decrypt or whatever you
want to call it for every image format
in the world we're going to go the route
of actually downloading a library to
help us with this so the one that I'm
going to use is something called free
image now I've never used free image
before which is going to be quite nice I
think because it's as you guys wanted
live video than you wanted to see the
entire process of engine developing and
whatnot you're going to see me use
something that I've never even used
before and I honestly haven't downloaded
this before even not imagine used it so
but I'm told is good so we're going to
basically try it out and see what
happens so this should be an interesting
episode but yeah it seems pretty
straightforward I read a bit of the
documentation in fact I'll probably have
to download the documentation because I
don't know how to use this but I believe
the yes so the binary distribution okay
so apparently it's it's already built as
well which is good so we don't have to
build it ourselves which will speed
things up a bit if we had to do that
that would probably be an entire episode
on itself and yes if you look at who
uses the free image for example you'll
see that a few big things like unity
actually do use free image so this
should be good so let's just grab the
the binaries because that's that's going
to be much faster what does this so does
this look like let's open this with I
guess reader so this is probably really
in-depth documentation I think the
examples will probably be better so
there are examples so let's grab this
free image let's pop it into our
documents in the libs folder
and let's quickly just take a look at
some of the examples so we'll go I guess
OpenGL we are using gel texture manager
so let's open this with sublime text pop
it over here and take a look at it
because that's what we do let's quickly
bring up two columns pop this over here
alright so it seems that so there's free
image yes okay so nothing really here
okay here we get load texture so file
name tax ID okay a bunch of image format
okay so that's just OpenGL stuff so free
image format fit unknown okay so that
okay unknown point to the image yes so
this stuff is generic as you can see I'm
looking for stuff like file name so file
name so we go v file image format equals
free image get file types of a purpose
first of all this is a procedural
library seems not that matters if it's
still unknown I guess if still on ok so
check the file signature and deduce its
format if it's still unknown get it from
the file extension okay that make sense
so it'll just read the dot PNG part of
the file name rather than the actual
header of the mobile file signature of
the actual file cool
it'll if it still it still can't find it
it'll just bail we check if it supports
reading then we I'm guessing we actually
load it so did with Dib and bitmap
embeds at the point of it okay cool and
then we get the bits from the Dib
and the width and height from the dead
and that's it so that that honestly
seems incredibly simple so hopefully it
is as simple as it seems and we don't
run into problems and hopefully stuff
like v supports reading will be true
because I think we might have to
download a bunch of plugins or something
I don't
we'll see but that looks pretty easy to
me so let's try this out so we're going
to literally try out this example so if
we get out of here and all we're doing
is we're trying this out now so let's if
zero our main and let's basically write
a new main method that is just our main
function that's just going to tests out
we want to make sure we know how it
works first and that it does work with
what we delve into actually into
actually implementing it into at a class
so if we go into libs and free image so
dest I'm guessing okay so we'll have rap
with rapper free image dot okay so this
will do see sharp yeah
Visual Studio 2005 fantastically old
dist 32 okay so there we go so this is
all we need we've got the header we've
got the this is beautiful this isn't so
nice and simple I'm really enjoying this
so far let's go into our Sparky project
Sparky and dependencies right we'll make
a new folder called free image will pop
this up into here how do we have it set
up okay we had including Lib so let's do
that so in include what's the shortcut
for I think it's control-shift-n and why
is this right-click taking so long
why is where to explore now responding
no no don't do that
control-shift-n yeah I include Lib and
my eyes my computer so slow with this
top not responding probably because it
has to add it in to like get or
something
I blame tortoise get for that ah Lib and
been so into our binaries we'll pop in
DLL will live in to lib and include okay
so everything is asked nice and
organized now so if we go to properties
and in just in debug or whatever we can
we can go to our directories and add in
free image include okay and in library
we can add in for image Lib and that's
it
okay so we'll probably have to add the
DLL it seems because it doesn't seem
like a static library at all but we'll
see so let's begin let's include free
image let's copy most of this code I'm
going to copy all of it except the
texture parts
okay so test dot PNG will try PNG
because that's probably mostly what I'll
be using
yeah see wait like everything looks
pretty good so let's after this we can
just go print me my width and height at
least so width ice and I'll maybe dump
all the all the actual image data
eventually let's just see if we can do
with an hi first so let's go into like
paint.net let's just make a quick 32 by
16 let's not use powers of 2 let's just
make sure you can do that I mean it'd be
pretty fun if it didn't but that was a
joke by the way anyway let's draw
something like a gradient of red to
white that's terrible
red to black there we go that looks nice
let's save that into where shall we put
this we'll put this into documents
project Sparky Sparky course source if
we just put it into here it should just
add it into our executable so if we call
this test doesn't matter I mean probably
going to save it as 24-bit I imagine
maybe maybe not this map will
auto-detect that we maybe get the bits
but there we go
let's test this out so we'll go through
this line by line because I don't think
it will work ok well we've got to add
the libs low but yeah and I should have
some more faith probably but
okay what's the lip cold no frame is
your lib who woulda thought that's
simple I like this library already yes
okay yeah it is a dynamic library get
out stop it
don't open 500 things please let's go
back into bin grab free image so now we
actually have unfortunately a real
dependency in terms of it needs to be in
here
we better put this in release as well
build okay
so file name good let's just initialize
all this stuff cool that's an old way of
initializing variables but okay what's
not all but it's different okay so let's
check the file signature did it work P&G
well looks like it's reading our file
okay since it got it from the header
fantastic I'm much more excited now
because I think this is this is
unbelievably simple if it worked
supports reading oh yes it does
get bits so yeah we'll have to actually
do that within height 32 by 20 ah it's
just beautiful it's just beautiful when
it just worked okay let's do something
let's just go through the bits
so where's what I what are bits that
byte so it's an unsigned char okay it's
a bite so for in title 0 is less than
when times height I plus plus let's
let's just dump it so bits I here we go
no it's going to just return okay so
it's just going to return us normal but
not exactly what we wanted but so let's
just cast them let's just cast them to
an end and see what we get okay so
that's each bit right so I mean 164 92
96 was the last one or maybe not let's
each byte right okay so first of all it
does look like it's in this is annoying
it does look like it's in the correct
format as in it might be BGR or
something though later this let's can we
can we work out the bits per the bits
per pixel we should be able to do
something like that
so get okay that retrieves the actual
image data but is there a free image get
channel what does that do
get yeah I want to see the get color
type maybe hmm
three image color type let's take a look
at the frame each header right if we
right click on this and go open document
so color type I think was a thing
there's a yeah that's not really what we
want what do we want we want the type
yeah so the type is Betsy that's the
type is still a little bit annoying
because that's the format how can we get
the actual like that looks promising but
it looks like there's just RGB a 16
which is different is it just normal in
16 like it's kind of annoying like yes
it's one of these but which one is it so
I would love to just find out what it is
color channel mmm yeah see that's a
little bit morning it's probably a way
to do it I just haven't stumble upon it
yet but hmm weird yeah these are all the
functions okay
so I mean let's just assume that it's in
like ah bits I really want to I really
want to get the bits per channel we need
to get the Vesper channel that's really
important
I might just Google this now when I see
the bits per channel so this is typical
development by the way ah this is not
really helping either
it's per-pixel that'll I mean that'll
also work what is that thing bits I
don't want the conversion just tell me
what it actually is let's go back up to
the top oh this is so annoying let's
read through this again but order
whatever I don't care about that yeah
these are pretty standard whatever yeah
so here's an 8 ohm which has this stuff
in it
that's image format ok free image type
let's look at this example all the time
and let's unload it at the end as well
probably
okay so we get we get bits which is just
a bunch of bytes which is just again the
bunch of advisors just unsigned char so
there one one bite each this is a type
def for that we get file type we support
reading but all my bits per channel all
my bits per pixel bits per channel bits
per pixel we've had bits per channel I
probably need the channel as well not
number of channels but yeah so free
image type where is that used here we go
get image type let's grab this get image
type and cube so let's see what this
gives us one okay I'm guessing that's
like the standard one so if we go back
to this and up to image type one is
bitmap jeez gee thanks
I'm just going to assume it's okay we'll
have to probably I don't know we'll
revisit this some other so I'm having
one of you guys will just leave a nice
comment being like oh this is what you
need to do to get the bits per pixel but
now that we have that knowledge we can
definitely say that well first of all
width times height is probably not
enough because it's in its so I assume
that that would be correct
I don't know let's try this out so bits
I space that space that so plus two plus
one so this is assuming that it's RGB
not RGB a but let's see what happens
104 one eight four seven one is that
correct no this is a bit weird see
unless there's alpha or something
involved okay well that's like what
color is that if that's even right again
I have no idea what the format is so
it's a bit difficult to actually see
against that okay so it's probably just
not read the image so maybe it is for
then let's try that
that's even weirder to thirty eight to
five four to thirty eight
that's like white I don't have that
color anywhere
hmm okay let's the example actually made
it into an OpenGL texture so let's see
what this does
so image format huh I should probably
just consult this to be honest so what
level but isn't that all just passed in
from here yes it is see what if we don't
know what the image format it's can't we
read it from the image that's the whole
point
okay let's um yes whatever so I kind of
like this episode because it lets you
probably see what's going on in my head
because this is the internal debate I'm
having one with myself because I'm I'm
talking to myself here so that you can
see what's going on but how did it put
it into OpenGL okay I just gave it bits
and it was in man signed by it and it
just gave it a little bits yes and it
relied on both the image format of in
tax reform at what if I don't know what
it is though so right now I just did RGB
and RGB see see that's why this is
annoying because I have to kind of guess
what the format is so 104 one and four
seven one is that eat like is there more
bits bits bits bits bits
so let's take a look at this from a
plane where's f12 hmm okay it just says
get bits
well actually you know what I do have
the documentation don't I
that's right here what was it called ah
free image get get bits
no where's the actual what more please
our next I have to click next to either
they just didn't mention it was lying
returns a pointer to the data bits of
the bitmap it is up to you to interpret
these parts correctly Thanks okay
according to the results of okay here we
go
wait PPP is that dead bits per pixel oh
my goodness I think I found it
gimme gimme just tell me where it is
there we go returns the size of one
pixel off thank you thank you
okay it's just an unsigned one find what
ah it doesn't matter
give me this give me all of it oh my
goodness oh my goodness thank you I'm so
glad I read the documentation um
I don't even know what this returns
what's this it's just a static hole okay
but what what's in the fudge factory
does that return what the what
that is interesting what I would expect
but
what in the I don't know what that
returns but Lowell okay ah let's assume
it returns an unsigned int or something
I might have to look at the source code
or something because they're not being
nice let's take a look at what that even
is 24 there we go
so that's 24 bits per yeah so it's 24
bit good fantastic we've now got a way
to do this so bits per pixel so it is 24
okay that's good so we probably
shouldn't be printing these as an end
first of all since they're but the
problem is I do want them to be printed
ah this is annoying let's quickly Google
how to print char as hex maybe a little
do I really want hex though I just want
printed as a number can you go away like
this think you can go away oh I want to
do this like ah I got another more than
that oh good bye
yes that's simple but no I guess I could
just printf it but I wanted to see out
way to do it see our printer is number
the plus okay apparently because what we
were doing before was we were
reinterpreting them as ants which means
that unfortunately it loses its like
incense ends take up four bytes it will
most definitely corrupt everything
because they're charged is one byte so
this should hopefully work that gave us
the same stuff I just don't trust this
um let's just print okay but now we
don't know if it's RGB or BG art so
that's the other thing so let's just
print it as essentially an integer so
bits I and we'll just we'll just print
the red channel about or the blue
channel depends 104
so there's anything 104 over here nope
ah what are we doing
104
I mean we would be at one point but if
it's three white bits this is byte
though these are the bytes so
sorry
let's just do this I'm giving up on this
whole thing let's just do this let's
just combine them all into a hex code so
x equals bits I will just assume that
it's the red channel volume that's yeah
this might be totally wrong but ah we're
going to have to trust it and we'll
print that out as X because I might just
be a interpreting it wrong so six eight
be eight four seven that's not that at
all so what is it I mean we've got that
color that's the thing it is kind of
close so it it sounds like something
we've got like somewhere online but I
don't understand why it's like it's not
going through all of them but it should
be
it should be because we're getting the
width we're getting high we're getting
the amount per channel so it seems like
that should be correct if we've got
three per channel which we do because 24
bits per channel and these bits are
bites actually they're not bits
they're bites I just see there's no way
to check how many of them there actually
are it's a bit annoying to be honest
okay we're paused over here let's just
take take a look at so many things
30 to 20 bits per pixel four bits yeah
we all know that this Dib thing
PNG file name is testa PNG is 24 bits
let's make sure it is 24 bits if we save
this as test and we make it to 24 bits
okay
just in case I don't know I mean it's
reading it at 24 so we still get that 68
thing so that's so weird though hmm
the other possibility is that it's in
just a different format such as this one
but that's not really going to change
anything and if that looks more wrong
because that means it's 47 3 8 6 8
I mean it looks like it's halfway
through this is ridiculous
almost everything is pointing to this
being for what but I know it's not
because compy yeah
that's most definitely wrong
I don't know - I don't know I might just
try and give it to OpenGL and see what's
up maybe I'm printing it wrong on
something I don't know maybe I've maybe
I'm just so tired that I just don't know
what's going on but it's yeah it's
certainly interesting 6 8 b8 4 7
so we had retrieved the image data
that's before we go one more thing I
might do is actually can you please go
away
I know I can switch between apps I don't
need you telling me get out
so trying to teach me um okay so ah I
see
that's why so I didn't have a return
type and whatnot
anyway um pretender pointer to the data
bits of the bitmap if you you just okay
yeah get red mask okay so we probably
look at them as well oh maybe it's not
maybe it's less than one byte per
channel or more this is so complicated
let's okay here we go
this is some reading magic no that is
so bits up for height or width yep it's
going to go through each of them bits
plus equals pitch pitch I'm guessing is
just what's pitch pitch I'm guessing is
just get like the other thing okay so
one more thing we should okay oh here we
go
let's try this well this is how people
work out how to use libraries by the way
guess you don't know so let's try this
so pixel I think this will just
reinterpret everything I should go back
and look though so they've got the pixel
while they do that for apparently
each why though I'm even more confused
now
we had pixel X and then the pixel has so
we have don't read dorinda blue okay
okay so let's try
let's try pixel I dot red ok let's try
what what is this what are you okay you
are struct so that should work shouldn't
it should but it's not integral on scope
no it doesn't have to oh well yeah let's
let's just pray this out red let's just
spread the red channel really looking
forward to this working maybe well
can you go away maybe else Emily um oh
this is okay what was it it was a float
okay
oh well maybe this needs fast nerve
that's still sad they were doing it
every frame which was a bit weird
everything that won't make any
difference no I can't zoom in a bit
so they're assigning it here for some
reason oh I see that's why they're doing
it because they're going best for
signals pitch but it'd be good if they
told me what pitch was because I hear it
has got getting pitch what the fudge is
going on this is the weirdest this is
the weirdest thing ever okay let's make
this whack X X X
okay so pixel X plus y times width
they probably I've been doing that
they're all a well they just doing that
but I guess we could just do that
we'll bring red and then here they just
go bits plus equals pitch be true pitch
ah you're still ridiculous maybe I
should be printing them or something how
is this even like working I mean that
assigning it looks like it looks like
they're assigning 128 just something
that's afloat so it's not in between is
heroin law okay this makes more sense
this is what I was doing before
wait that's if it's RGB F this is this
is getting annoying
okay so let's ignore this I probably
should write that first or we can remove
this if image type is a fit bitmap and
if it's 24 okay that's good that's what
we did 24 then I going to go through and
purchase the thing but
let's let's just steal this real quick
Garrity's whoa oh my goodness
I tried to steal it but it didn't want
to be stolen why do they have next line
here weird but okay all right so
everything is just the best I think
we've already got that there but it's
assigning it why why would you be
assigning this like are you checking it
or something
oh and okay let's bring back our little
friend longest episode ever
that's what happens when China doesn't
know how to use the library and uses it
all right ready is everyone ready
that did not sound good
Lal what
I was that because it was not what's
that horrible sound or that horrible
sound it sounds like something's not
working but 71 that's still not what I
wanted isn't oh whoa
it was 71 over here somewhere do you see
it what the fudge factory is going on
this is this is this is really weird
I'm going to have to probably study this
overnight or something what the pitch is
legit so that's totally okay I know I
mean it idiot it looks like it next line
that goes on to the next line and then
we get some kind of like problem but I
don't really see it as a problem like
it's a sound it didn't happen that time
I don't know what's going on 71 180 well
that's what we're getting for wasn't it
I'm pretty sure all voice it's pretty
sure that's what we were getting for 71
184 104
that color is definitely in our image
somewhere you know what let's just try
this probably should have done this a
while back let's just change this let's
make this like 8x8 and let's set it up
with different colors this is probably a
bit much better way to debug it so we'll
start with blue we'll go to like that
color that color keep one red we'll just
make like a kind of rainbow thing oops
and we'll see what's up 0 71 83 is that
correct no it's not so 183 is correct so
there is 71 83 what that's the top one
suspicious so it did eight pixels of the
top one this better not be what I'm
thinking what the fudge it did it in
reverse order you serious
why so it started here and read it like
that it seems yes that's exactly what it
did I bet the first color is going to be
this one it is we're done boom
you